hello my friends it's Clements here with
a quick preview of exodus blue a
mid-sized competitive map in destiny
coming exclusively to PlayStation this
map is available as part of the crucible
PvP mode unlocked at level 5 first
things first let's take a look at the
map itself designed around the Exodus
blue colony ship that once served us
during the Golden Age it's not doing so
hot now but that's okay because
guardians stay positive Bungie has
designed this crucible map for infantry
competition optimized for both three on
three and six on six matches and look at
this place
primo real estate people and classic
Bungie fashion Exodus blue is built with
nuanced exteriors for rich complex
firefights it's also set against a
gorgeous backdrop that's a little
depressing with the fall of humanity and
all but remember positivity Exodus blue
supports five different gameplay modes
for crucible players skirmish control
Salvage clash and Rumble now what you're
seeing here is a skirmish which is
pretty straightforward team-based combat
here's a little pro tip just because
you're awesome if your ally goes down
during an active firefight don't revive
them unless you have some cover you
don't want to bite the dust twice in a
row do you how humiliating that
certainly never happened to me before
for those of you itch into play control
on this map here's an early warning from
the pros point B is tough to hold so
cover your entrances and communicate
with your team if you're looking for
some delicious destiny secrets find the
broken pipe near the fuelling spool
which can funnel you from one side of
the map to the other pretty neat last
but not least let's give a silent round
of applause to our Guardians demoing
this map because they're equipped with
exclusive PlayStation gear including
this stylish Armour that would totally
win fashion awards in space all of these
beauties are level 20 rare gear sets but
the upgrades available are more powerful
than any other class of item boom
the bottle one on to the next fight
that's it Guardians you can stomp
through exodus blue yourself exclusively
on playstation when destiny launches on
September 9th please consult a doctor if
you experience hype lasting more than
four hours
you